test niveau difficile crash bandicoot
salut prêt à relever le défi du niveau
le plus difficile de l'histoire de crash
bandicoot j'espère le voir bientôt dans
une vidéo
ciao depuis la sortie du premier opus de
la franchise en 96 crash bandicoot
recèle un sale petit secret un niveau
caché inclus dans le cd rom originel
amputée du jeu au dernier moment telles
amendes gangrené car tout simplement
trop ardue a remporté son nom stormy
hasselt
challenge accepté ma la fa cup alors
comme ça s'annonce du petit challenge
barmaid sur un niveau soit ni de l'antre
du roi ainsi dû convenir du jeu au ça va
cartonner games et j'avais oublié la
porte sont grassement ty coat pas vexer
les diables verts stormy à celle d'
aller allons-y alors à quoi ça ressemble
conseil bonne chance tu vas en avoir
besoin
ah ah ah ah tu t'es dans le ski il n'y a
jamais de chance soffer stone à la bombe
bien ok alors il faut savoir que je n'ai
pas joué au remake de crash bandicoot
donc je fais le mec moment tout se passe
bien je suis désolé mon d'accord il ça
me tue ça si je me le prends à temps aux
aa
c'est dur c'est impossible
arrête avec tes fiole alors c'est quoi
le piège des démarches olala j'anticipe
la sortie as-tu vu merde c'est pas que
je sens franchement je veux lui j'ai un
pressentiment
on va jamais on va y arriver oui y avait
maintenant maintenant on m'appelle
louvier quoi ok en fait y compris délire
je combats d'hier faut que je saute plus
loin soit pas la prière plateforme de
manière a immédiatement sauté sur la
deuxième marche put à la mer le bison
omap à l'homme dès la la la la la la la
c'est comme ça que jo le composter son
en studio j'ai vu une fois faire ok je
me faut un mec se supprime chaîne
youtube
2 tu peux dire plus poliment with amer
je lui parlais je vous jure que la
hausse est super dur je sais pas comment
j'ai fait mais voilà mes mecs ses fins
il fait quoi lui ok il ya une centaine
in the air soit ok go ok super j'ai raté
est meilleure et sa grande marne a déjà
d'où un brave fait de mettre à l'essai
bon allez salut oh la la halakha loeb ne
commentez pas ce qui vient de se passer
surtout pas je pars à 0,10 à tuer
non je vais arriver je vous jure je vais
avoir un orgasme d'une puissance quand
je vais arriver là ou là ok mais c'est
pas tout de suite mais ça m'arrivait au
[ __ ] dit alors [ __ ] mec mais qu'on
est loin on est loin vers le futur ok
faut faire quoi c'est quoi ce poison
qu'est ce qu'il fait là on va lui
marcher dessus toujours marcher sur un
ennemi dans le doute
calculez c'était calculé
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vient de se passer non ne
dis pas ça dit plus tôt à beaune toi là
la comédie ça il n'y a plus de problème
ça me dérange plus [ __ ] mais j'ai tout
moche et d'une traite ces fois où c'est
plus beau chant peut plus que le pigeon
on est bien l'oiseau tout s'assemble
oiseaux il est mort qu'est-ce que je
fais là oh oh [ __ ] mec là je serai
plus jamais jusque là oh [ __ ] mais
qu'est ce que je fais il ya du stress là
c'est quoi ça checkpoint
oui facile anticipé ça c'est bon il fait
ça j'avais envie qu'on revoit le jour
mais il hésite il est bien modélisés je
trouve que les gens n'en parlent pas
assez sur youtube y est [ __ ] mais
qu'on a plus de vilains faut réussir à
thébaux squeeze merci mec hockey point
de contrôle à toutes nos vies alors ça
c'est l'épreuve la plus chiant
maintenant on y va on est paré pour le
combat à mais [ __ ] mais glisse mec
quelle idée d'acheter des pompes avec
aussi peu d'adhérence qu'on doit faire
de l' escalade y est on là la mecque
oh là là mais [ __ ] mais je mène avec
ses longs cheveux âge aurait dû analyser
l on y va d'un d'une traite hockey ni kg
c'est exactement la jouer le double pitt
va bien vous en faites pas ça va quand
j'avais encore une vie c'est incroyable
c'est comme un coeur
pièce en quel point de contrôle pointent
drôle mais non mais qu'est ce qu'il fait
mais si tu aimes les flics je fais toi
piercing fait tout à trac [ __ ] minimes
oblige à sortir des punchline de merde
acquis pourriels personnes 1 1
il ne bouge pas [ __ ] prime tu tiens
c'est jouissif qu il dégage comme ça
vers l'écran non non non make the
parlotones bonjour j'aimerais avoir le
numéro du créateur de crash bandicoot
s'il vous plaît j'aimerais avoir le
s'il vous plaît c'est un jeu sur
playstation
alors il s'appelle jason rubine oui
alors il est brun il a les yeux bleus et
il a créé car je mendie côté j'aimerais
lui parler c'est très important
peut-être lui envoyer un mail pour lui
dire de bien [ __ ] saba
deux harkis je vais faire une musique
les fans musique samuel courage arrivent
ils pensent voter sur la plateforme
passé niveau comme un bonhomme escaut
nord de crash bandicoot allait
chaussures réglé il faut en prendre un
petit escalier scala v est rescapé mais
ce connard d'escalier était en fête
vendredi rebonjour aux cycliques s'est
récemment ce serait chic mais sous sa
blouse se cache en fait un point fort
c'est un peu
il pense pouvoir gérer ce type aux
attentes est un problème d'ego mais se
rendront sans fil idéaux qu'en fait tu
pue la merde c'est ballot pour ta vidéo
qu'en fait tu es fan niveau
c'est ballot vidéo
aurait des bas niveau
[Musique]
alors les amis ça vaut 100 locale
monique all daouda puisqu'elles
n'étaient pas les meilleures habitudes
on parle en tout plus de 40 ans au
canada cinq fois la [ __ ] mec ce jeu
est tellement dure visant à bâtir retiré
du jeu à l'époque quand même pas ce que
c'est c'est déjà c'est un niveau de plus
il est toujours ça de pris soin de
laisser un truc niveaux bonus comme ce
qu'il faut actuellement avec la la
nouvelle trilogie classement du coup de
phare à la remasterisation et bah écoute
et j'avais l'impression d'avoir huit ans
et de jouer sur ps1 avec mon frère qui
me regarde derrière moi ça m'a fait
plaisir j'espère que vous aussi je vous
dis à très hauts prochaine inversement
regarder désolé je n'ai pas été à la
hauteur j'ai été mauvais à alonso dans
une prochaine vidéo c'est parti ça
[Musique]